how's the gallon - Pierre - ha I just
replayed a missile because I lost my
save yeah but now we're gonna do the
truth part of the game I don't really
know what the [ __ ] it is but you bros
were crazy about me playing it so I
guess I gotta do it I guess I gotta do
it what should I name my character well
I'm gonna go with Cordelia podiayia
whatever fine congratulations on beating
the game did you enjoy missile yes thank
you
now then and a new story awaits you one
you have thus far yet to see oh really
none of what none what none know what
may happen now you're prepared know who
would actually I'm clicking no just to
see is that all right then I'll shall
take my leave
well [ __ ] okay no why did I write mr.
Padilla yeah that makes sense okay well
I'm ready this time because I'm a
mystery man girl welcome to the new
story
all right so this is Tyler new game in
the game oh that's beautiful music
though just makes me wanna dance
strange strange see she says strange -
where'd it go maybe I picked it up
without thinking about it and then I
just could be it is that me so uh what
is that what is it miss ah she spoke to
me
holy [ __ ] I just dropped my contact tact
I think it's around here somewhere
miss Howe over eyes are [ __ ] creepy
I'll look with you
thanks oh that's beautiful live together
now miss Howe never got much attention
but she was really nice
why would a girl like that do such
things I don't know maybe she does not
well we found out the truth didn't we or
I guess that's what I guess mr. Purdy
Bedelia hmm someone's calling me I've
heard it before
what the [ __ ] is going on here huh where
am I I was just in class I was nodding
off in class then then what happened mr.
Padilla yeah when you go out eyes I own
iguana Oh [ __ ] wanna miss our negawatt
Oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
well so that's where he got his name
from what the Frick are those crows are
those breakdancing men all those are
those guys who moon at the supermarket
and show their day as though that's an
army full of those huh okay what is this
this is mr. Ernie Guevara it's been a
while mr. Fidelia actually no it's to
spend about three minutes mister [ __ ]
why the heck did you call me here the
truth is I thought I would offer
liberation to the spirit that had to be
sacrificed the [ __ ] yoshino and the rest
you can do that but why that girl Missa
went a bit too far indeed what they did
is unforgivable but her death was not
their fault they suffer just as much I
think it's too cruel to allow that
suffering to continue as such I have
decided I release their spirits if you
do that will you will everyone come back
that's impossible
sadly but if their will to live is
strong enough they could possibly be
born again okay I will try to say will
you try to save them mister
Delia I'll leave the choice up to you
why me why not Toma his friends would
everyone trip a lot I confident you are
the only wanted to take them because I'm
bald and bald man does know a lot of
[ __ ] you can quote me on that breasts no
other would be able mr. aney guara i
have high hopes for you but white
alright so can i same thing yeah yeah
what is this guy what does that guy do
say like guys I hate pants want to save
well I'm [ __ ] guerrilla by that [ __ ]
so these are all the be careful the
spirit of the man who killed me saw is
still up there alright so which one
should we take kuda we don't know that
much about Cudas i think we should pick
him or maybe I got the name mixed up
that's a green haired guy right oh
they're on a sweat sniff sniff sniffing
coke and [ __ ] that's not good or sand
probably what's wrong
Takeshi keep teasing me not again not
again
wow they're there I'll take care of
duckie she don't cry
Takashi I remember that Kashi okay let's
go home I'll protect you on their way
that's so sweet
that's a slider man it's protecting her
there were childhood friends huh well
who woulda thought I wouldn't thought
actually you were so kind then but you
changed he's just walking off without
her realizing it was [ __ ] high as
[ __ ] so now he's a douchebag in school
wait
pant pant
why are you getting ahead of me let's go
home together please hey you've been
acting so strange why are you ignoring
me get some sense you're the annoying
man sorry I know I'm kind of a bother
but I try not to be I'll try to do
things to my own I promise I won't
bother you so
so annoying what never talk to me again
[ __ ] [ __ ] why why would it be so mean
oh [ __ ]
Oh miss our let me say offer a hack know
why the heart giving me the lip what
does that mean how you know what
happened yet she twisted her nipple I
can see that [ __ ] triple dot cord nip a
lot he doesn't even do anything my [ __ ]
you know what I'm gonna be honest I feel
like if you don't act if you see someone
get bullied and don't act on pilot kit
bras and kids and everyone you're just
as bad at the bully you gotta do
something you're bad in me I trusted you
I won't forget you you did it that does
this is bad just as bad you can't do
that you gotta say it stop and slap them
in the face where is it where is this
and then and then and then call their
parents and tell on them don't do that
do whatever you want to do I don't even
know what is it darkness
am i playing you mini key again oh stop
it already
what the [ __ ] is going on die die
already supplying this yo yo yo you
forgive me miss ow
died in a fire burning stop stop
die I hate you
diam what okay that's anyone I gotta
write that down it's great material on
this hour thank you okay kudos stay with
me Kudo is useless die already miss out
please stop I'm suffering I'm stuck cut
a place come back with me forgive me
there's no point grieving
if I only had bit quicker that's my
follower life oh no it's not your fault
but it is miss out loaded me this is
utmost proof of that it's all made to
play CUDA
no these guys aren't visa the
disillusioned brown from the darkness of
your heart ha ha ha What nonsense what
do you base that a pun because this
sounds so nice genius she wouldn't say
these things don't you know that
yourself
Misao miss ow that was great
CUDA miss ow but this sound CUDA calling
me your first name you haven't called me
that in so long
sorry Kudo no I should be apologizing
it's my fault you it's fine I don't hate
you why I mean why didn't I abandon you
yes it was very lonely
I suffered like I was gonna die but it
before but I knew how you felt Kudo
I just lacked courage I knew you were
always thinking of me and that made me
happy regardless ha thank you for
thinking of me I love you too cool
Misao oh but sadness ow who appeared in
front of kudo the real I wonder if that
missile was just an illusion of kudos to
we will probably never know what are
your breath thing and he became a baby
how [ __ ] splendid all right well I
guess we're gonna do I gotta save her
and see what happens over here should we
save the others froze I feel like yeah
why the [ __ ] not
Yoshino all right
let's see what that guy goes trail did
who's Yoshino now again that's that the
Eve that's the evil girl right the bully
you sense presence nothing and it's my
[ __ ] open missile don't be a bad girl
maybe you'll be good I'll let you out
the fog open okay I'll go to sleep or
some [ __ ] no stop it stay away stop help
no I'm scared it's dirty it hurts
it's gross ow ow ow that's a song right
there you ladies in it out our our [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what about the window what
never for kiyose what do you look like a
sugar fly never forget what that watch
that watch
forgive me for getting this out now Oh
who's getting punched now gay ah damn
girl
oh yeah help ha ha ha I can't get away
with what you did to me value is this
punishment but I know you suffered
yourself so I'll see you if I want you
stop and find how you feel you're just
gonna regret it soon I guess it anyway
oh wow later oh okay
if only I couldn't fight how about this
urinals the salt in here that's it
I can stop bond JD has ten snacks again
alright your [ __ ] song because why
the [ __ ] not
alright take that nope it won't do
something so awful I sprinkle her with
salt better think of something out [ __ ]
what about selling her ah - got a fast
release the [ __ ] baton is urea not
stop it miss ah forgot one down on Jose
tres ole balladeer Amato Mara garena own
dos tres
dun da da da da ba da yo Sheena Oh
doesn't look like she can speak oh yeah
she know it's fine now no last I why
Yoshino I hope this was has taught you
not to be a bully I've I'm sure she lost
the kid permeability speak I'm sure miss
I will let's head back together okay
why oh [ __ ] Bros oh [ __ ] nightmares
tonight what why are you getting in my
way I thought you wanted to help me I
thought you were my own friend well not
that you know there was this guy here
with a badge you see that [ __ ] now [ __ ]
that was not me yes I always want to be
a friend it's habit letting you do this
wouldn't help you at all what are you
missile you haven't passed on yet if you
keep doing this you'll never be able to
shut up well that's rude listen miss out
we're doing this really clear up your
heart quiet
of course it won't if it did you only
have whatever the extent that send it
shut up shut up shut up stop this
massage you're just being vengeful I
don't want to see you like that silent I
kill you how'd you know I was lame
oh she's a baby they're all little bro
little Justin babies all right breast
that's all the time I had for today